we make way for Doug Gottlieb who is
done yeoman's work filling in and we
appreciate that all the great effort
that you have in quality that you bring
when you fill in for us and we we
appreciate that so thanks for joining us
yeah I like to do the juxtaposition of
when I do this show as opposed to when
you guys do the show obviously it makes
you guys look a lot better thank you -
thank you
that's fake humility on your part no
obviously it's me begging no I've got a
pie in the face I've done you know I get
up at 4:00 in the morning in California
driving to the show and I just don't
want to get a pie in the face this year
well you had the pie coming to you last
year when we were in Houston that was
great because I gave a pie to of
somebody in the audience and I said look
we're gonna get a team picture here with
Doug when he joins us and all of a
sudden Doug didn't realize that there
was somebody who was coming out of the
crowd to smash him with a pie you
actually also told me that they took
gullible out of the dictionary and I
believe that one
we got the Fab five t-shirt if you know
I think it's only available through
Tuesday and it's a take-off on the Fab
five design from Michigan limited
edition March Madness shirt only
available through the NCAA tournament
the Dan Patrick show app or Dan Patrick
com
download the free Dan Patrick show app
today what's on your mind
well I think that the helmet the helmet
the helmet rule to me yesterday and
doing the show with Jimmy Jackson and
Jimmy played football growing up I
played football growing up and obviously
he looks like he could still be a
football player as a big Steeler fan I
think the immediate reaction is whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa too much but then
you stop you take a breath and it's
pretty obvious that the NFL has to react
to what so many former players are going
through and I mean look if you even look
at the the Saints play in which was
Marcus Williams the the rookie from the
Saints the reason he didn't make that
tackle was he was trying to avoid a
penalty it said he was leading with his
head he was that the rule when we grew
up playing football anybody was see what
you hit he had his head down and that's
what they're trying to take out of
football and you have to take it out
from the top down because raising a
nine-year-old son who wants to play
tackle football and I haven't yet him
let him yet everything they see on
Sundays is what they do on Friday nights
and I actually kind of I in the in the
three hours of doing your show yesterday
I came to agreeing with the idea of it
is it as you pointed out it's it's hard
to decide intent but they're not saying
every time there's helmet-to-helmet
they're ejecting and there's gonna be
some mistakes and there is some gray
area but the idea is a sweat like when a
quarterback slides if you leave with
your helmet you got a chance to be gone
I don't see anything wrong with that but
if you know you're looking at this if
you lower your head it used to be you
know a defensive player lowers his head
then it's a weapon why is it and we've
been saying this for the last four years
you can lead with your helmet as an
offensive player but we don't look at
that as a weapon but part of the rule is
that now running backs and and linemen
Ken can be included in it why I don't
know I mean and look part of what we
love in highlights is the running back
trucking the the cornerback or the
safety and lowering his head and running
over him I don't know what you you know
what you do with that call I don't know
but I do know that the idea of you know
what happened with Ryan shazier did does
he need to be penalized in addition to
coming back from potentially being a
quadriplegic probably not that was you
know I think was jeopardy but yeah the
idea of it is the right one which is
like hey look offensive players can
spear a guy defensive players in spirit
i if you lead with your helmet if you
try and hurt somebody with a crown of
your hat you have a chance to be ejected
from the game and I don't think anybody
if they take a breath thinks that's
actually gonna change football I had a
couple of basketball things
Marvin Bagley junior the third decided
he was going pro I've seen some mock
drafts where it sort of fluctuates it
feels like Aten is the best player but
if you had the want number one pick
overall I would take Bagley and look I
understand that Aten looks like a man he
looks like Billy Madison playing
dodgeball right it's like they just we
all look like children around this guy
was a man-child but if you watch the way
the NBA is played you have to have
versatility on offense and look I'm not
taking and anyway shots at Aiden but I
don't think he helps you as much on
offense is as first oh he can play in as
many different lineups as you can play
you can't play small ball with him if
you watch the NBA if you watch college
basket ball merely collar collar the NBA
has stolen from college who has stolen
from Europe small ball is here and it is
here to stay and it's because of and
this is a lot like the NFL the way the
game is officiated until they figure out
how to clean it up around the paint
where you can't put an arm bar or put
you know or just mug a guy so he's it's
hard to there's a reason that a post-up
is a low efficiency shot it's because
the defense is able to mug you and so
players are developed facing up up in
the basket I think Bagley helps you far
more at the offensive end obviously
right now
Aten helps you more at the defensive end
but there are lineups to which you can't
keep him on the floor as agile big guy
as he is I don't think you can keep on
the floor against a small Ball lineup
and so I would go Bagley one and that by
the way was the presumption coming into
the year I think eventually it'll work
out that way as well in it interesting
you brought up European basketball and
you were soft if you played European
basketball you came from Europe you were
soft
now we've adopted that so-called soft
style of basketball but it's far more
entertaining you're far more skilled why
were Europeans getting the knock that
they were soft when they came over I
think it was I think it's the flamboyant
way in which they they flop and they
they draw attention to fouls but I also
think it's that you know we were we were
taught you know when you drive in there
you jump in you draw a foul you create
contact you get an aunt one and you know
when we grew up watching 1980s and early
90s European basketball they're driving
and they're kicking out four threes and
we're like dude that's soft right
shooting a three instead of a hard 2 is
soft and then you're like wait a second
there's a certain kind of math to it
maybe they maybe they know something we
don't
and yes they still smoke in Europe yes
they some people still don't wear
deodorant in Europe I would still much
rather live here than there but they
were ahead of this 3 is more than 2
things but we just get West had a head
of did he understand European basketball
at loyola marymount was that anywhere no
that was in terms of pace of play that
wasn't an efficient style that what he
did understand and I think I got a
chance to coach a team in Israel last
summer and you either you either adapt
or you die right and we played the
Israeli national team we were getting
run off the court and I was
figuring out like what are we doing
wrong and you start to realize that the
24-second shot clock you have to change
the way you coach completely from a
30-second shot clock in that ball goes
in the basket you pick up and you press
three-quarter court so that you don't
have to defend nearly as long and so I
think some even college coaches have
struggled to adjust from 35 to 30 it
does change the game so I think that
when Westfall did well going back to a
little amount was they they played tempo
they didn't play defense that was about
can they were winning based upon
conditioning you know I remember when
they had bow and they had Hank
they were playing Oregon State and Gary
Payton and I think Gary Payton's team
had like 72 at half and they were
they're up 20 at the half and then all
of a sudden you get too late in the
second half and they couldn't make a
layup because that was a big one based
on conditioning your tire yeah not based
on efficiency so I I do think there are
some coaches that have been ahead of it
his was more about pace of play and
conditioning than it was about the
European style per se what the guy Paul
Paul Westphal but yeah Paul Westphal I
think also captured some of this and
then you look at the Mavericks maybe
were the were the first one they played
small ball or wouldn't Nelson and Don
Nelson or when you go to the Suns and
Mike D'Antoni when he brought kind of
the Shawn Marion becoming a power
forward changed the NBA forever and then
of course now you put draymond Green as
your Center and that's that's set that
set the NBA world spinning to where you
look at what's the t names you guys
watch the McDonald's all-american game
last night right so as I'm Williams
since a dunking monster left-handed not
much of a shooter he reminds me of
there's a kid named shake hot and there
was a couple years behind me in Southern
California never made in the NBA was he
was actually on the cover of Sports
Illustrated as the he was gonna be the
first guy to go straight from high
school to the NBA and he never he
actually never made it but they remind
me of each other and people will say
well you know he's six five and Raymond
six five so he could be a small ball
center like do you know how good dream
on is defensively that he can guard five
positions
that's why draymond so good nothing
offensively he's okay makes enough shots
to keep you honest so the everyone in
the NBA is searching for a small ball
Center they're no longer searching for
the 611 lurch that sits on your bench
and collects dust
as far as this tournament how does loyal
to win this game against Michigan you
know it's it's fascinating traditionally
the mid-major has to play small ball to
beat the high major right they got to
spread you out and shoot a bunch of
threes it's kind of how Michigan plays
actually right look I think it's really
hard to guard Michigan in in that they
spread you out so much and then you're
so concerned you're so consumed the
entire week about what they do
offensively that you look they're
actually the best defensive team this
year in the Big Ten they're really
really good but coaches I think by and
large they all come out of the Michigan
game going you know we didn't worry
enough about their defense how are we
going to score and this is a Michigan
team that could have been beaten by
Houston yeah I think what you have to do
is you have to they're better five as
one than they are one on five and by
that I mean at both ends of the floor
Michigan's talent is not movig nor might
be the only NBA player on this team but
outside of that and they probably have a
mismatch there against a freshman Center
who's more of a true big guy for Loyola
I think you have to do what Houston did
which was try and isolate their
defenders they're really good doing
what's called loading to the ball
Villanova does that you put the ball on
the floor everybody is around the
basketball they make you kick it out and
they got active hands I think he got a
spread amount you have to turn the ball
over side to side and find the weak link
defensively and attack them individually
it's the same thing offensively you have
to make them beat you going one-on-one
not not constantly playing scramble
defensively where they penetrate in and
kick out and you don't know who you got
and they make a jump shot how big
historically would this be if Loyola won
the national title I think it would be
massive I I kind of think at George
Mason because they probably shouldn't
have been in the tournament would have
been bigger and taken down you know
Florida who won two national
championships but remember when Butler
got to the national championship game
they were a preseason top ten team with
two NBA players preseason top two right
Clayton Guster couldn't play he wasn't
good enough to play at Iowa State and
he's there he's the Missouri Valley
Conference Player of the Year and they
probably should have been in as an
at-large but they wouldn't have been in
as it at large I think you could
considering they won their first three
games by four points yeah and they would
beat John Beilein and then either have
to be
Nova who won a championship two years
ago or beat Bill Self where he won a
championship Bill Self is one I think a
billion consecutive big 12 titles like
not officially a billet billion but
close to it I played in the big 12 it
feels that way it just it feels like
when Michigan just right in Kansas has
big 12 champion until further notice
I think it would be the greatest upset
in modern modern college basketball like
I can't go back to the UTEP days or
whatever okay
if you were in your prime in college so
you're 21
yeah would you be the best player on
this loyalty' team yes okay yes I mean I
look at some of that see go talking but
some of that's also okay I'm just maybe
people don't realize that you played at
a high level for your I don't know where
you are but I couldn't shoot that would
be a problem but I think I think if I
don't want to figure it out I made a
shot last year so we'll just roll back
the tape of last year I dunno I could do
better than all of the people are you
playing with with weighted basketballs
no no no it's just you know what is well
it's happening there people came out and
started shooting and couple their shots
look like epileptic seizure
it didn't was it was I almost feel like
they're pulling your leg like there all
right let's get Gottlieb up here now
they're all just gonna start throwing it
in like Pleasantville if God leaves
making fun of you shot you know you
looked really good until the result that
was the problem
did you have the yips yes yes and it's
and it did did Mark Hill folks have the
yips
I think absolutely think he had the ups
by the way when he came back to
Philadelphia he got a warmer reception
than like war heroes like Mark Ellis but
it's like he just he had a bad shoulder
and wasn't playing well and so they sat
him down and he got a the warmest
ovation I've ever seen in a Philadelphia
I will tell you where my my hip started
the first ever Big East game in Notre
Dame and Rutgers history played in the
rack we had a 14-point lead and they
started to come back and I got to the
free-throw line night air ball the first
one and I made the second one and we get
back to South Bend the next day and it's
a Sunday and I have a red light blinking
on my phone and my dorm room
and it was from coach McCloud secretary
coach wants to see you and so John
McLeod would never call you out he was a
former NBA coach you'd never call you
out in front of the team and he called
me in and he wanted to talk about the
game like the previous night in in
Piscataway and it's dougie what do you
see here we put on the tape and we're
not watching the actual game we're
watching my free-throw and I was like
well that's an air ball coach and I go
with it but I know I made the next one
you know like I'm like all right what
else do you want to watch and we watch
it over over again and so we go out in
the court at the and now it's the
pavilion Purcell pavilion then it was
the Joyce Athletic Conference of the
jack so go by the court and he starts
and he'd never played basketball ever he
was a boxer and he swam before games and
so he actually called Denny Price Markin
and Brent prices dad who is his former
assistant coach a shot guru and he
starts you know working with my shotty I
want to get your left hand in front of
the ball and I start shooting the ball
like 1950 style my left hand in front of
the ball and I think between that and
some of the pressure and honestly like I
lifted weights I got a got jack that was
back when creatine first came in at
Notre Dame I put on 17 pounds of muscle
but not steroids no no it just creates a
water weight you look a lot better than
you actually are I couldn't make a shot
and it kind of gets in your head gets in
your head and then you get fouled to get
to the free-throw line everybody's
watching you like dude I'd like to be
anywhere but right here right now and
then you go back in college you watch I
would have stuff times when I was
shooting you know good percentages and
then I just I just lose it it would feel
like stage fright and so yes I think
marquel Ford said Sejal okay during this
live look in yeah are you gonna have
stage fright shooting a three here in
front of this audience yes you hit last
year I actually I don't know until I
touched the basketball like right before
the right before you're about to shoot
you'll feel like your legs just go just
go all right then we'll see we'll take a
break
Frank Martin's gonna join us one of the
all-time great guys they wore his
basketball shirt like he's ready to play
coach is ready to play I was gonna wear
mine but we had this like deluge last
night this rainstorm last night I had no
idea what the weather was gonna be like
yeah I remember Peter King more pair of
shorts one time at the Super Bowl not
that wasn't that was wrong yeah but just
camera angle was not good that day just
not good and I think he had John
Stockton sure
on two so that didn't help as well those
are back in style now yeah I hear that
I teach Doug Gottlieb Doug thank you for
stopping bike for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]